we're celebrating jackie robinson dane
today the number 42 being honored today
well and simply put because he's having
success and has added layers to his
arsenal he is a bonafide starting
pitcher in the major leagues and adrian
hauser ready to roll the brewers on an
incredible run a franchise record eight
consecutive starts
five innings or more only one run or
less it has never happened
in the history of the brewers franchise
number 42
fly ball into center field and
appropriately enough
jackie bradley jr makes a catch for out
number one and away we go
both of these offense have been swinging
and missing
smash off the bat of evans but on a hop
out to second base for jace peterson
that almost undressed adrian hauser look
out yeah
came off the bat 102 miles an hour
and the 2-2 pitch swinging and a rocket
down the left field line and gonna be
caught
nice running grab
by billy mckinney it'd be a challenge
for brubacher as matt capps said moments
ago two games so far this year he's 1-0
with a 193 and nine in the third innings
pitched turn on home runs
jackie bradley jr sends a fastball out
to left on the first pitch reynolds
right there
waiting for it to come down and he'll
make the catch one out on one pitch
nicely done there you go love that
my goodness
i mean that's pretty nice start
jeez four pitches you like that
wow
wow what a start for jt brubacher great
start you can't ask for much better than
that now colin moran will lead off the
second and he's got great career numbers
against hauser six for nine with a home
run here's the 2-1 and a swing of the
ball lofted to left and deep mckinney
back to the wall there it goes a home
run for colin moran
the opposite way
and on the home run leaderboard it's the
pirates one and milwaukee nothing he
loves to go the other way i mean just he
stays back tries to hit the ball hard
that way doesn't want to be out in front
and
look bad on the off speed pitches that
i don't know for positive but i'd say
that was a change up that he hit out the
other way looks like a change up out of
the hand
look at this foot down hands back
explode towards the baseball what's that
make him 700 seven for ten
number 34 delivers in a swing and a
ground ball out of short to his left
newman spins fires throws onto first to
get garcia by a half step one out
high fly ball polanco
with just enough room
ground ball
mr brubaker keep this up
a five pitch inning
the opening series in san diego in
2018's got me all flustered fowler
swings and misses at a high fastball
first strikeout for
adrian hauser one up and one down in the
third
see what he has in mind here one and two
the count got the speedy frazier at
first and there he goes and the pitch is
out thrown a second on the money in time
and a caught stealing
narvaez cuts him down at second base
1-0 swing the line drive down the right
field line this one hooking into the
corner it's extra bases for luis suryas
he's into second and he will stop there
with the leadoff double to open up this
third inning
takes a look at the runner and delivers
right there strike three call a fastball
at the knees on the inner edge one out
and the pitch
right there strength three call frozen
with a fastball four strikeouts right
side of the infield is wide open good
speed on the bases the pitch
inside of that hit casting ooh that one
got him right in the left elbow
travis shaw celebrating his 31st
birthday today will hit with the bases
loaded against brubacher
struck him out right down the middle and
how about that reaction
he was excited
[Applause]
two and two now on moran
and a swing animus
see the difference down in the zone like
that
popped him up
gonna be close coming right down the net
over there to make the plays shaw he's
got it
how about adrian hauser and a pump of
the fist
i think that's important to him
frazier two previous trips tonight fly
to center reached on an infield basement
and that is fair inside the first base
bag
this will score newman
and fowler and frazier headed to third
and he is there with a stand-up trip
trip
triple and the pirates lead by three
it's three-zip and that brings up brian
reynolds
hard hit to right field how about that
two out bingo for b-ray headed to second
and he is
safe i love it the hustling battling
buckos bryan reynolds makes it four to
nothing
an all-star closer
roller
evans to first and the pick on the other
end is that
[Applause]
oh
pretty
gotta love this look at that off-balance
throw
sorry one out single tyrone taylor will
come up
swinging in a rocket to the gap in left
shutter gonna get off the wall out there
this could score a run
around third is peterson here he comes
and the brewers are on the board
on a double by tyrone taylor travis shaw
represents the tying run for milwaukee
up the middle but right there is newman
they had him
positioned perfectly to end
the fifth
oh that's it
jt brubacher with his seventh strikeout
tonight crazy stuff
pitch
right there strike three call back door
slider at the knees that was beautiful
jt brubacher with eight strikeouts
tonight and for the third consecutive at
bat shaw is going to hit with men on in
scoring position and the pitch
and a swing of the high fly ball out to
left but playable
reynolds just shy of the track will haul
it in one pitch one out three left
stranded two outs and gregory polanco
will come up
[Applause]
that's hammered towards center field and
in milwaukee we're gonna have a cup of
coffee for al cafe
a two-run shot his second home run
insurance against devin williams
the buckos
love to see it brownie
6-1
look at that popped it up
way up
when it comes down raise the jolly roger
the bucks defeat the brew crew in
milwaukee what a start
to the road trip